testing your way to greatness in 2026
and beyond. This is the current set of
best practices that are working right
now as it relates to Meta Andromeda,
what you're going to do on the platform.
At the end of the day, all the old
school best practices are obviously
invalidated as a result of Meta
Andromeda existing. So, we have to
update how we test and we have to update
our ideologies and our beliefs about
when testing is most appropriate and
when it doesn't make any sense at all
and is technically going to [__] you.
And you also have to just understand
campaign structure in general. This
relates in its entirety to what we talk
about as a central focal point on this
channel, which is cracking
million-dollar months. Whether it's the
first million a month or the next
million a month, we just sit here hand
down lessons from people that have been
there, done that. What I'm talking to
you about tactically today are from the
lessons that we use consistently in my
marketing agency where we spend a
fuckload of money month in and month out
very profitably for the deals that we do
that we have net profit shares on. These
are also lessons that we hand down to
our Jeremy and our circle members, our
master internet marketing students. We
consistently see incredible results
across the board across many different
business types, mainly high ticket
product and service-based businesses.
So, if you're new to the channel,
welcome in. It's a pleasure to have you
with us. Just quick earnings disclaimer.
I have no idea who the [__] you are and
whether you have literally any
probability to go out there and make
money. I am not saying in any way,
shape, or form that you are going to
make a million dollars a month or let
alone a couple million bucks a month. I
don't know if you can turn money into
more money. And the odds are extremely
low. There is a 0.1% probability
according to the US Bureau of Labor
Statistics that you ever hit $10 million
a year, let alone the even smaller
quantity of people that ever crack
million-dollar months or the even
smaller quantity than that that would
ever crack a couple million bucks a
month. So again, there's no earnings
claims. There's no income potential
here. I'm just sitting here handing down
lessons from people that have been
there, done that, talking to you from a
scaled perspective. Ideally, you're
already sitting here doing a couple
hundred grand a month or you already
surpassed a million a month and are
looking to get there for the first time
or the next time. So very excited to
help you out in this video. Without
further ado, let's dive in. The first
thing that we have to talk about is
campaign structure. Okay, so the way
that we're currently testing is very
different compared to how we used to
test. So here's how our actual
structures work nowadays. We typically
run with two campaign types. And I want
to be clear, the second type of campaign
type, when we look at warm audiences
specifically, we'll barely run traffic
to those unless there's a warm audience
that's sizable enough to actually make
it worth spending some dollars on. You
can always run it, but it's going to be
a very lowbudget campaign. And we like
to obviously do things at scale. There's
three adsets within this cold campaign.
We have broad, we have an interest
stack, and then we have a lookalike
stack. Okay? By stack, I mean we'll take
a fuckload of, as an example, the
interest stack, interests, behaviors,
demographic traits. We'll load them all
up into one giant ad set. We will not
separate them out. Again, targeting is
controlled by messaging. Nowadays,
targeting is rarely controlled on the
adset level like it's historically done.
That's an example of an archaic outdated
belief. Messaging controls targeting
nowadays. So again, we throw all these
into one big old ad set because the
broader usually the better nowadays.
Lookalike stack is the same way. I
generally create a bunch of 1% lookalike
audiences based on things like highest
value customers, customers, leads that
showed up to calls, qualified calls that
booked in. There's four examples for you
in addition to whatever else you may
also find valuable. Point I'm trying to
make is we just create a big old stack.
These three ad sets then all contain the
exact same ads when you go down to the
adset level. So on the ad set level, I
usually launch with about 25 to 30
unique ads. If you have not yet done so,
I have an incredible training on my
channel here dedicated to all the Meta
Andromeda best practices, how it works,
some messaging best practices as it
relates to it. We've gone in depth on
this on this channel many times over.
And by the way, this started rolling out
in November and December of 2024. They
were isolated testing it. April of 2025,
they started rolling it out to a handful
of accounts. by July of 2025, it was
ripping across about half the accounts
and you're watching this right now, like
this [__] with an extremely high degree
of certainty has already been rolled out
on your account. And if you're not
updated to this set of best practices,
you're getting absolutely [__]
cooked. Okay, but I digress. I won't
make this whole video about all the
specifics on Andromeda. I'm trying to
keep it centric to creative testing. You
can go watch those other two videos if
you want more in-depth information,
education, and frame on how Andromeda
works from a deeper perspective, and
I'll cover it here with you. Back to my
point, following the Andromeda best
practices, we need messaging
diversification. So, we will create 25
to 30 individual reasons that somebody
should go and convert on our offer. And
we will put those into individual ads.
That's right. We will not take a
different hook and attach it to the same
body and CTA. We will literally film 25
to 30 total unique through and through
creatives with very specific reasons to
go and convert. This is a very important
best practice as it relates to
Andromeda. Okay. Now, onward and upward.
Besides the 25 to 30 unique video and/or
image ads, we'll also typically do five
pieces of body copy and we'll do five
headlines. One thing for all my
extremely detailed folks that are
tweaking out that I didn't already say
it is these are the same five headlines
and the same five pieces of body copy
for every single one of these 25 to 30
ads. They're written in a way where
they're broad enough to have
applicability across the board. Okay? We
don't want to have to go and write five
headlines and five pieces of body copy
for every single individual ad that
exists. That would be exhausting. Long
story short, we also typically find that
about one to three of these ads are
going to get all the reach and all the
distribution. And so this is the next
most important part that you have to
understand in terms of an outdated
belief. And that outdated belief I've
seen really [__] people in the modern
scape with Andromeda. Here's what people
with the outdated belief think and how
they behave subsequently from holding on
to that view. outdated belief is every
creative deserves distribution. It
doesn't. Okay? You're going to feel like
it's wasted effort when you go launch 25
to 30 ads and one to three of them get
all the reach. Okay? That means, just to
put it in perspective, let's say that we
launch with 30. That means that we are
going to have 27 to 29 with little to no
reach. Like they'll have spent pennies,
maybe if you're lucky, dollars. And
you're going to be like,
>> "Well, look at the [__] videos. They
didn't get any reach." Like they they
No, this is terrible.
>> And you're going to get [__] as a
result of that belief. Because here's
what you're probably going to do next.
What you're probably going to do next is
instead of running this simplified
structure because they still give a deep
[__] about account simplification in
case you didn't know. You're going to go
and over complicate your ad account,
you're going to create an insane level,
an insane level of audience overlap.
Okay? And you're also going to try to
distribute creatives that the trillion
dollar company doesn't think should be
distributed against the ones that are
more probable to convert and get you the
outcomes that you're optimizing your
campaigns for. So, what you're going to
do is you're going to take one ad set,
you're going to put one ad in it, and
you're going to duplicate that ad set
[__] 25 to 30 times over, and you're
going to put one unique ad per ad set.
That way, those ads can all get reach
and distribution. That's what you're
going to do if you hold on to that
archaic belief. And I want to be fair
and saying, are there instances where
that can still work? Yeah. If that
starts to work better than what I'm
currently saying, will I abandon what
I'm currently saying and start doing
that instead? Yeah. Cuz guess what? I
don't give a [__] about being right. I
give a [__] about making money. Here's
what I've seen. Because you have to also
understand I mentor literally thousands
of people, hundreds intimately and
hands-on work with about a dozen
different deals at a given time in our
marketing agency. And we actively unlike
you, test against what we think is the
right thing to do to prove ourselves
right in reality rather than just in
theory. The structure that I'm telling
you here with these three adsets inside
the cold campaign optimized for [__] By
the way, we'll do [__] for our budgets
rather than CBO. That way we can control
distribution amongst the adsets a little
bit. We'll go down on the ad level. One
more little pro tip and we'll make sure
none of that stupid [__] when it comes
to the AI advantage creative stuff is
turned on. No site links. No site links.
None of the little [__] talk. The
only one that I like right now to be
fair with the AI creative [__]
advantage stuff that they're pushing is
the one that highlights a positive
comment. I do like that one. All the
other ones can get [__] You got to
make sure all those are turned off. this
specific structure of those three
adsets, broad, interest, lookalike
stack, the same 25 to 30 unique ads,
same five pieces of headlines and body
copy paired with each one of those, it
just absolutely rips right now. And
every time that I get somebody who joins
into one of my programs where I
intimately mentor them, like my Jeremy's
inner circle offer, links down in the
description if you want to check that
out, I see inside of their ad accounts
and I'm like, "What the [__] are you
doing this for?" They share that archaic
belief that, well, a bunch of my ads
weren't getting reach and distribution.
you know, I followed what you were
talking about about loading up 25 to 30,
but you know, 27 to 29 of them didn't
get reach. And I I felt like how could
they be determined a loser if they
didn't get any reach? And again, I
totally agree with that logic. I don't
disagree that that's a logical thought.
I'm just telling you that this structure
just [__] beats the [__] out of that
other structure where you duplicate an
ad set bunch of times over and put one
ad in it. It's very important that you
understand that because what you think
you're doing is you think you're doing
creative testing. When you duplicate out
that single ad set a bunch of times over
and you put one ad inside of each ads
set in order for that ad to get all the
distribution. First of all, you're
getting artificially inflated costs.
That's one thing to really consider.
That's what we find time and time again
when we test. We just get an
artificially inflated cost compared to
what this structure would produce. And
on top of that, this is the most
important thing to understand. We still
do creative testing. It's just a little
different. Okay, so let me get back to
that point. When we have this structure
right here that works, okay, here's what
we start to do. We will have an ad set
and out of the 25 to 30 ads again 1 to
three will be determined as winners.
Okay? And when we get this combination
of winners right here, we will start to
scale it. Okay? Which most of you never
really do. You get stuck in testing your
way to poverty. My goal is to test my
way out of testing and get to the point
where I can scale the [__] out of
something. So we start to scale. Okay?
As we scale and time has passed, usually
we hit a ceiling. Okay? And with that
ceiling, there's just a hard limit where
we don't get the opportunity to spend
above it. Every single dollar that we
spend above that ceiling, the cost per
result climbs, the result volume drops.
And so what we do is is we decrease the
spend. We push it right back down to
that ceiling. The ceiling becomes the
key. We then convert this into what we
call a foundational campaign. Or if
you're running [__] it'd be a
foundational ad set. Okay? Now, watch
this. Let's use the example that that ad
set was one of the three, like my broad,
my lookalike stack, my interest stack.
I'm at that point when I've hit the
ceiling and I've scaled the [__] out of
that ad set and I've got my one to three
winners within that ad set. I'm going to
duplicate it. Okay, so what I do, okay,
this is the if this then that logic.
Okay, so if this happens, okay, then I
duplicate the ad set. Okay, and when I
duplicate the ad set, what I end up
getting is a new ad set that has the
same targeting. Okay, and on the ad
level, I have those 25 to 30 ads. Keep
in mind, a majority of which did not
distribute. Okay? So, for the ones that
got no reach, those are the ones that
we're absolutely going to keep inside of
that newly duplicated ad set. The one to
three that did get reach, we're going to
pull those out. Okay? So, again, we're
going to take these, we're going to get
rid of them. And ideally, what we're
going to do is we're going to add one to
three new ones, too. Okay? And with
those new ones, now we're back up. We're
fully calibrated again with 25 to 30
ads. We have one to three new ones in
there that replaced our winners. And we
have all these other ones that didn't
get any reach and distribution. Okay.
This then goes back to a test budget.
Okay. So, whatever you determine your
test budgets to be, that realistically
be where you'd want to put this. Okay.
Now, inside of this newly duplicated
adset, yes, it's okay that it's in the
same campaign. You then repeat the
process. So, we get to the point where
we then see the exact same thing. Okay.
So, we'll have one to three new winners.
Okay? And out of those one to three new
winners, if we like who's coming in from
them, if we agree that the types of
people that are now coming in as a
result of those one to three specific
ads getting all the reach, if we like
that type of person, we're going to then
start to scale it. Okay? Now, this is
very important because I'm going to lead
you to another set of if this then that
logic. If we launch an ad set and the
one to three winners within that ad set
sucked, okay? Meaning they're
technically working like they're
bringing in the result you want. They're
technically bringing in a cost per
result that might be favorable, but you
go listen to the calls or you see who
shows up to your webinars or you just
look at the leads in general and you
hear the feedback from your sales team
and they're saying like, "No, these
people suck that are coming in." If they
suck, okay, and you don't like who's
coming in from it, then you duplicate
this. You remove the one to three that
are getting the reach. You now call
those, even though they technically won,
you call those losers. You try to stay
away from that types of messaging. And
you do that process all over again where
you now have a newly duplicated adset.
You're going to kill the loser that you
just duplicated from in that example
because it lost and it has one to three
losers running. We don't want to put
budget towards losers. And then what
we're going to see as a result of this
is we're going to add again one to three
new ads. We're going to get to the point
where we start to see some victory
again. Okay? And we repeat this process.
It's just a if this then that scenario.
This is how we currently scale. This is
how we currently create a test. A lot of
you guys tweak the [__] out. just to
address a few key beliefs real quick so
you guys can thoroughly understand this
and like really get to the point where
you're making some serious money with
paid ads nowadays in this postandromeda
world like you if you are the type of
person that just wants to see every
single ad get distribution and reach
because the logic behind it is I want to
see which one actually wins you don't
end up actually getting anything other
than just an inflated cost per result
that's all you actually get from doing
that you're also [__] tweaking out
because you're like oh my god I have ads
that aren't being used that I spent time
filming it's like there's literally no
problem with that at all. We think that
that's a great thing, not a bad thing.
We want to have ads on the side. So,
when ad fatigue occurs, we can relaunch
that ad set and we can overcome it. When
we have an ad set that has some losers
in it and we don't like who's coming in
from it and we need to duplicate it and
launch some new ads, we'd obviously want
to have some ads laying around on the
side so we don't have to go and film and
start over again. You know, the craziest
part to me, whether it's a Jeremy's
Inner Circle member, whether it's a
master internet marketing student, it's
never with clients because we'll have
them, we'll be on their ass about
filming and we'll be on their ass about
getting us those videos and then we'll
edit those videos for them. But to be
clear, it's like the speed in which some
of you guys take to just film new ads
and then edit those ads is unfucking
believably intolerable to me. You guys
take forever. Okay? And if that's you
sitting here watching this, that's all
the more reason you would constantly
want to have ads on the side. Even if it
takes you only 24 to 48 hours to film
ads and turn them around, why would you
still justify a wasted 24 to 48 hours?
You would always want to have ads on the
side just chilling, waiting for
launches. Okay, so this specific
structure when it comes to testing your
way to greatness, this is how it works
literally right now while I'm sitting
here telling you this. And I just want
to be very direct in telling you this
too. There's a lot more to this that I
don't share here on YouTube, okay? I
share the real sauce inside of all my
paid programs, which you can check out
links for down in the description. We
have Jeremy's Inner Circle, which is for
rich people trying to get a fuckload
richer. Twice a month, one-on-one calls.
If you're in the full Jeremy's inner
circle, four times a year, we do
masterminds here in person in good old
Miami, Florida. You're welcome to come
to those. If you're in full Jeremy's
inner circle, we have the weekly group
calls. We have a big old library for of
all the historical weekly group calls on
all the historical masterminds. We have
unlimited access to Jeremy AI, a massive
SOP library full of 35 plus SOPs.
There's a really active community and
Telegram chat. There's a lot of other
stuff that comes with it, too. Check out
the link down below. And there's a
wellcreated video there that by the way
starts off with the price straight away.
So you can see a great example of VSSL's
too if you go check that out. And
regardless whether that program is for
you or not, I would encourage you go
check out the master internet marketing
program, a 7-week live class, one-time
transactional cost, lifetime access to
the program. Every year we go back and
we update all the material. We look
forward to helping you through one or
the other. And whether you're going to
do that or not and just check out more
of my videos on my channel. Thank you so
much for being here. We deeply
appreciate it. By the way, one last
thing. Came out with a new vlog channel.
It's Jeremy Haynes Vlogs. I'm doing more
get to know me content on that channel.
Whereas here on this main channel, I do
all my talking head content with
trainings just like this. So, go
subscribe to that channel as well if you
haven't checked it out already. Thank
you so much for being here. Go get
richer.